[Music]
she started hanging out with a gentleman
from work and began cheating on her
fiance she wants to be with him and i
think that ultimately he would be her
choice in order to be with him she has
to marry him choose the military life
for the next three years she doesn't
want to be with him she wants to be with
the idea of him
[Music]
what's up this is john with the dr john
delony show we are here and we're
rocking on
so glad that you've joined us if you
want to be on this show give me a call
at 1-844-693-3291
it's
1-844
six nine three thirty two ninety one or
go to johndaloni.com
ask a s
k
i just got back in town from a trip
speaking at a university
and
um teachers people who teachers who have
been um
one to one five years i think they come
back in the summer for an institute and
it was extraordinary it's so fun
um we'll talk about that some some other
time i have to tell you this story um i
was
i fly southwest whenever i can they're
great
and um and all the airlines i've worked
with except for one is pretty great
um
so i rented a car
when i landed in dallas to drive to the
city a couple hours away and i rent a
car with budget i just got online rented
it did all the stuff so i get there
to get the car
and i don't have a credit card so i just
don't i don't roll with credit cards and
so i have a debit card and so um i've
got plenty of money on my debit card and
my bank knows i'm traveling all that
stuff just simple phone call and it just
works fine
so i get there and they're like well we
don't really take these
it's like what do you mean you don't
take them like well
you have to do this and then sign this
and then do this and do this and
basically it's going to double the cost
of the rental i didn't understand
said well we have to hold this much
money that's fine i know that they got
gotta hold some money that's great but
then it became well we also have to do
this thing and we have to do this thing
i didn't have another option so i said
okay cool we'll just run it
and it runs and it declines it
what in the world so they say hey um we
can't run this anymore you get um or if
we run it one more time you only get two
declines a day then you have to wait 24
hours i said number one let me call my
banks i called the bank and they were
like what are you talking about you have
plenty of money and we know you're
traveling you're fine
so then i put on speakerphone and i said
we all say that again and they said yeah
you got plenty of money here um
just tell them to run it again we're
looking at the decline and it's clearly
on their side
it's not on our side so i said and they
and they heard this they said great so
they run it again
declined and they have another machine
over here and they said we've been
having trouble with machine but
anyway
um
[Music]
they run it it declines and they said um
sorry you gotta wait 24 hours i was like
okay that's cool but i need a car now
because i got to somewhere i got to be
and they're like well
we have a policy that says you can only
get declined twice and i said i know but
you heard the banks it was your fault
and they go yeah i said can you just try
that computer over there and then the
manager comes over and he's like sorry
man it's the policy that uh
and we got to a point where i said hey
listen
can we find a way
for me to give you my money
i just i just want to give you my money
can we figure this out
i said 24 hours we're happy to uh
so they just canceled
everything and then i didn't know what
to do
um i thought i guess i could call a
buddy or i could try to get a flight
from dallas to this other city and
that's always a mess
so i just walked outside and got on a
shuttle
and i went on the enterprise shuttle and
if i tell you i got to the enterprise
place i have no i have no product
placement with them this isn't an
advertisement for them i have no nothing
i have nothing i paid them full full
everything
i walked in
and everything was bright
and welcoming
and this woman named devry
she said hey
we all take my debit card and let me
rent a car and she's like for sure come
up here
within four minutes she was walking me
out the door
to a car and sent me on my way
and she was so kind and everyone in the
enterprise place was they were laughing
it was just a different environment and
i said
it feels like you'll want to take my
money
in this business and she was like yeah
that's kind of what business does is we
take our customers money and then we
give them a car
all i have to say is this
thank you enterprise thank you devry
thank you all for showing up in a time
of need for me
and for i i won't bad mouth budget god
help them i'm not gonna use them ever
again
but
if you're gonna have a business
that's uh let me let me put it this way
i feel like there's a swath of
businesses these days
that is
trying to tank itself so that it can
sell
and i mean that's me as a complete
hypothesis but there's a group of people
that i i've done business with across
the country
they wake up every day deciding like i
want to serve people whether they're
working in hotels whether they're
working in rental cars whether they're
working in the airport whatever like we
want to make our customers lives eat a
little bit easier a little bit better
and we're going to figure out how to
take your money from you too for that
service which i think is great it's a
that's a great transaction there's other
companies that are trying to figure out
ways
to just do less and less and less and
less and still call it the same service
into those companies stop doing business
because i was fortunate i'm a privileged
guy i had money in my sit in my account
um i know how to try i travel a lot if
that had been a family of four
without a lot of margin who needed to
get to a funeral
man they would have been a mess an
absolute mess
and by the way my deal at enterprise is
about 300 cheaper i don't understand how
any of that works man all i have to say
is if you're running a business
let's lean into that old zig ziglar
quote
if
you help enough people
money will always take care of itself
and if you have a business that's
struggling right now business is not
going well right now
reimagine okay let's stop
focusing on we're hemorrhaging money
where this because that's important you
got it that's the business
focus on man
let's help as many people as we can
let's go back to the people that use our
products and let's help as many people
as we can and the money stuff will take
care of itself
that's just my wisdom thank you devry
shout out to you thank you to the
enterprise gang there in dallas at
dallas love
stepped up big for me and my family and
those group of teachers
um thank y'all so so much all right
let's go to lynn in boston hey lynn
what's up
thanks dr john thanks for taking my call
all right thank you so much for calling
what's happening
um
so i gotta tell you after that story
these pretzels are making me feel really
well done
so so my situation so
i have a 19 year old daughter
she met a really nice young man last
summer great qualities great family
values just overall really nice young
man
he enlisted in the military at the end
of last summer so their relationship was
short to begin with
they continued their relationship we
attended his military graduation with
his family
he came home at christmas time asked her
to marry him
so they're currently engaged okay
a couple weeks ago
she started hanging out with a gentleman
from work
and began cheating on her fiance
um yeah so
i confronted her we had a long talk
i let her know that i didn't agree with
what she was doing and i couldn't
support it
i told her that i understand that she's
in a very difficult situation
and i don't agree with her choices but i
did offer to walk alongside her if she
were to do the right thing
so you know i suggested that she pause
the relationship with the new person
and speak with her fiance and let him
know exactly what was going on
and i also suggested that potentially
because it was such a sticky and hairy
situation that she get a counselor to
walk alongside her with with her
and agree that you know i offered to pay
for it and
she scheduled an appointment with a pet
with a counselor
um stated that what she was doing was
wrong and that she wanted to speak to
her fiance about everything
but i found out last week
that she didn't stop cheating didn't
pause anything hasn't spoken with her
fiance
and to make things worse
she's planning on going to see him with
his family at the end of this week oh
wow
does she live with you
she does yes
who does she work
she does she she works full-time um
during the summer and then goes to
college and most part time when she's in
college
ma'am
i'm going
so before i just start answering
questions i want to make sure i don't
answer questions you're not asking um
okay
because i have a visceral response
across the board on this as i know you
do too um
so
how can i help let me start there
well i guess i just have this guilt that
i owe him the truth right his family the
truth
you know and i'm trying to get her to do
the right thing and come clean with him
and
you know
i think she's having a hard time with it
because
she wants to be with him and i think
that ultimately he would be her choice
but in order to be with him she has to
marry him now move with him choose the
military life for the next three years
and being 19
i honestly don't know if she's ready to
make that obviously we know she's not
ready to make that choice but i just
think that yeah she doesn't want to be
with him she wants to be with the idea
of him
because being with him is is it
comes with
all those things you just mentioned
right my wife wants to be with me and
i'm a lunatic right i'm a lot
and
we live out in the woods and also i work
in media and so we get stopped at every
dinner we have now like so but she wants
to be with all of me
not an idea a romanticized picture of
what you might part of you does that
make sense
yeah and so yeah she doesn't want to be
with him not by a long shot she wants to
be with this idea of him
um and that's a huge difference
yeah um
so
man
i'm gonna probably end up giving you a
recommendation that i don't normally
recommend
um
first and foremost
you seem to
like this guy more than she does
and that's pretty common and it would be
cool
um i think you're gonna have to keep
that to yourself
okay okay um yeah you like this guy and
you it's i can just but by your
description of him you if if we
fast-forwarded four or five years you'd
you would love for your daughter to have
ended up with this guy right
certainly so there's that um before i
before i start
running my mouth here
did she learn this at home anywhere
or is there any sort of deceptive
we kind of just keep things quiet just
put your head down does she pick that up
anywhere i would say communication
hasn't always been
key um so maybe
actually
tell me a little bit more you said that
very in a very uh flat flower
communication hasn't always been key
i mean that's you know i've had
relationships where it's like like i'm
in a relationship where i could totally
communicate better you know
so
but the cheating like i no there's been
no never been deception as far as that
like i've been cheated on in my life i
was with someone that had a fiancee and
i didn't know about it did you did you
tell her that
yes
you know i've explained to her that i've
been on the other end and it sucks yeah
yeah okay you know so
here's the thing
um when it comes to addiction
i often
buck the system and if it's safe
i always want people to have a place to
come home
and the conventional wisdom in some
circles is you kick their butt out of
there when they get their life back then
they can move out and i know that
addiction is a connection issue right
um now someone's not being safe or
whatever then they have to go stay
somewhere else
but in this situation it's different
because they are actively
hurting somebody
other than themself and i know addiction
hurts everybody i know all that but
what i would tell her i'm just thinking
if this is my child
you are not welcome to use my home base
as something as a platform for you to
actively hurt somebody
in the way that you are
and
the important thing here is is that she
is making this choice not you
right so you are not kicking her out as
much as
she is choosing to leave
and i think it would be really important
for you to sit down and say hey one of
the cornerstones i've thought about this
more
number one i haven't been great at
communicating things and i'm gonna start
working on that getting better like when
i have to have a hard conversation i'm
gonna i'm gonna start taking proactive
steps to get better at that and i didn't
model that for you well and i'm sorry
but the more i've thought about what's
happening here and remembering being on
the other end of this
um one of my core values is to always
tell the truth
and to never
cheat or deceive somebody even when it's
hard
and
i can't allow
i i am choosing to not allow that to
happen here i want you to live with me i
want you to be here but if you're going
to continue to actively
enter into the destruction of somebody
else's life
long long tail destruction on this deal
um
then you're choosing to go live
somewhere else and i hope you'll make a
different choice
does that make sense
yeah totally we've had i mean we've kind
of been leading down that road where
i've you know given her
not really the ultimatum but i've said
like you know you need to tell him that
you in or if you don't then i will be
forced to have that conversation either
with him or his parents and i
i don't think that's the right move for
you i think that would be such a
violation of her trust over time
um i don't know that that's the right
move i think that she needs to bear the
weight of this as she's an adult making
adult decisions
um
and i really think it's important that
she understands she is choosing this
yep not there's she there hasn't been a
line in the sand whereby mom has to uh
is weaponizing a relationship that's not
what's happening here mom has a set of
values that i'm choosing to not live
into
so i'm choosing to leave
and that sounds subtle but that's a huge
difference because then every phone call
you have
when she's moving is
i hope you'll stay here i really hope
you'll stay here
um
how do you think this ends i hope you'll
choose to stay here and not choose to
leave
but this is one of the values that is is
you have to have to live in my house
right
and yeah i would say this this is hard
but she's welcome to break up with her
fiance and i hope you'll still love her
if she breaks up with her i said i don't
care what you choose you know but that's
that's your choice i just want you to do
the right thing yeah be a person of
integrity make a choice yeah make a
choice and it doesn't even have to be
either or it can be you you can you can
make choose you yeah and you know put
the time and effort into you and
figuring out what you want you know that
what's going to benefit you in the long
run
but just remember 19 year olds are still
they're not listening as much as they're
watching
and that's where
you're walking through a very clear hard
conversation is going to provide a model
for her to have a very clear and hard
conversation
using words like you know kinda we've
been thinking or communication's kind of
key
it's got to be very very clear
i spent some time this last week writing
down my values and i should have done
this a long time ago and i didn't
one of them is we tell the truth and we
are people of integrity and right now
you're not being a person of integrity
you're you're willingly intentionally
trying to hurt somebody
and i think that's what bothers me the
most it is and it should right it it
should yeah and
this would be if this dude wasn't as
he's a great guy and that makes this
example easier even if he was an idiot
he was a scumbag you don't still don't
do that you know what i mean
you still put that out there so
um i would spend some time with my
values and i would spend some time being
honest with her about i haven't been
good at communication and that's gonna
change and so here's where we are um
here's our values and maybe she'll join
you she probably won't but maybe she'll
join you in a values exercise and say
who are we going to be
who
here's who i'm going to be i want to
know who you are planning on being
because right now every minute every
hour every day
the actions you take or don't take
is contributing to the person you're
going to become and let's be intentional
about that let's just don't wake up
somewhere on an island to be like how
did we get here let's be intentional
about who we're going to become
and one of those
core
core values and virtues is i'm going to
be a person of integrity
and um then you have to have a hard
conversation about here's a boundary of
mine and i hope hope hope you'll choose
i'll hold your hand while you make the
call
um
i'll fly with you out there if you wanna
do it in person whatever that looks like
[Music]
um but yeah and for
god almighty don't go on a trip with his
parents
that's just
oh geez that's just gross man
that's gross hey thank you for loving
her
and sometimes love comes with hard
moments of boundaries and accountability
and it's hard it's hard
she's lucky to have you we'll be right
back
hey what's up delona here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done
it's that deep feeling of exhaustion
after a long period of being overworked
and overstressed and just fried and most
of us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at betterhelp betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get
percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com that's betterhelphelp.com
all right we're back let's go to daniel
in rockford what's up danielle
not much how are you doing i'm dr john
we're partying brother
good thank you for taking my call i
appreciate it absolutely man what's up
well i've got this uh thing i've dealt
with for as long as i can remember and
i've i've
been thinking about when uh in
preparation to make the call and i'm
trying to describe it as clearly as
possible but
basically whenever um
i need to speak up for myself or perhaps
correct someone
i usually have a severe anxiety and get
like a
fight or flight like
or freeze response
and
i usually don't and i'll just kind of
exit the situation without speaking up
for myself or even for others and
it's led to some really disappointing
situations and just really silly things
like
that shouldn't have to happen that i i
don't know why i can't do it so
give me an example of a situation that
you
um struggle with your response
um
like it ranges from very
basic interactions with people like
um like if i'm sometimes like it's been
as bad as if i've been at a restaurant
and i've ordered something and they give
me the wrong food
instead of like even speaking up and
saying hey i didn't order this
or something like that i'll just like
eat it and pay for it and
not speak up or like it's been as like a
family situation where
i had uh
because i'm married married without
children but um
i've had someone in my family that did
something that offended my wife
and she asked me to
deal with it and i didn't know how to
deal with it and so i backed down which
she's been gracious with me about but
it's not something i wanted to what did
she what did she ask you to do fight
some dude in a parking lot or
call somebody didn't say that was
offensive
no just address something that was
inappropriate that
someone
uh
i'm trying not to go into details but
basically uh
there was a
oh i just said something something one
of my family members did made her very
uncomfortable uh okay and
i i should have addressed it and i was
i was nervous because i it made me
uncomfortable as well yeah and i was
trying to figure out how to
address it and deal with it like and who
who
who told you that
how you feel doesn't matter
or is is it is a burden
um
somebody's i put that in your head or in
your body who gave you that
i
i i guess it has come from my parents
sometimes like
i know uh when i was younger
i had
sometimes i had issues with like making
decisions or i would say like
uh
i would basically be discouraged from
liking something or
like hey i like this and like no you
don't really like that like you just
think you do
and so i can hear you right now
daniel trying to defend them
and you're defending them because you
still think you're wrong
even though like hey i really want to
play
um
basketball basketball's stupid you
should play football any idiot plays
basketball only real men play football
and in your head your six-year-old
little head you think
no i i want to play basketball but i
that guy's big or she's really smart
i guess i'm the crazy one
is that does that ring true
yeah and you find yourself out in a
football field with pads on doing
something you don't want to be doing and
now you're getting hit and hurt and
whatever it's because it's not something
you're interested in
and
were you responsible for the emotional
well-being of the adults in your in your
home
were there things you didn't say because
dad would get mad or mom would fly off
the handle
um
not quite
but looking back on it there was
i did see uh
how this is i did see that
um
i'll say like my mom had a strong
emotional response to like
she was like really over kind of
overprotective of my brother and i
and so like
this
like i don't know how to say it's right
but like if my
if my father had like
over corrected us in her opinion
she would like really defend us
or or
sometimes it was just
i would see that there's a strong like
emotional like conflict between the two
of them and so i would try to
smooth things out and also my mom was
kind of one of those kind of
uh buffering kind of personalities where
she likes to
make keep the peace with everyone and
try to
keep calm so i kind of inherited
inherited some of that before as well
you didn't inherit as much as you
just absorbed it right it just because
the air you breathe your job is to make
sure everybody else is okay
and
somewhere along the way that became
you value the feelings of others more
than your own
and in fact that has
you you
see yourself in the world as a burden as
a bother
and
what's strange about that is or what's
unfortunate about that is is you know
what a restaurant really really wants
to get things right
and if they mess something up
and
somebody tells them with with dignity
and
and integrity and and respect hey man i
you guys brought me the chicken salad i
actually ordered the ribeye and um
oh my gosh let me make that right
you're actually helping them out because
they want you to leave really happy you
see what i'm saying and so it's actually
taking it from them um same as your wife
right um
a family member one of your family
members does something or says something
that crosses a line in her minds and she
says
i can't be a part of this i need you to
help
and
you're unable to help because well i i
that person's feelings are more
important than my feelings and now since
i'm married that person's feelings are
more important than me and my wife's
feeling right so
i want you to stop beating yourself up
over this first okay
okay this isn't a moral failure and it's
not a character it's not a character
failure
okay i want you to start thinking of
this as a skills challenge
okay you don't
if you're bad at basketball it's not
because you're a bad person it's because
you haven't
shot a lot of shots
and so moving forward
you know where this comes from you have
a peacekeeping mom who also fought all
your battles for you and you have an
overcorrecting debt you know where this
comes from
now the word i want you to keep in your
mind over and over and over is this word
called practice
that's it practice okay
i want you to
identify that discomfort
when you have to have a um excuse me i
give you a 20 out of 10. i want you to
feel that real quick
and then practice practice saying
something
and here's what we're doing
we're just teaching our body because
your body has a
put a gps pin in
if you push back
it's a nuclear response and you need to
teach your body that that's an
inaccurate pen that the place that it
has pinned is no longer there it's
actually moved to another place see what
i'm saying
yeah that makes sense because
it's like it's a very visceral response
you know like yes but then but then that
visceral response turns into inaction
which turns into shame which then
heightens your body's
detection system for any other awkward
situation which then
you freeze again right and you you feel
this thing just spinning and it starts
getting faster and faster and faster
right
exactly and then your wife says will you
help me out with one of your disgusting
family members and you're like
you can't
to which your wife responds
frustratingly and then you feel shame
because you know you should say
something set your family and you don't
and then all of a sudden the next
situation you start you start getting
anxious about being anxious because
you're going to another family thing
right you know what i'm saying
yeah let's pull the string on all that
all that
i'm just gonna practice
and it might be as silly as getting one
or two buddies who know you and love you
and you say hey what i need this can be
ridiculous
but uncle so and so said this to my wife
and i gotta say something and i've never
done this i'm gonna practice this
okay
it may be practice with your wife
and spoiler alert i do this with my wife
sometimes hey i'm about to have a hard
conversation at work or with a colleague
or something i'm saying about think i'm
thinking about saying these three things
four things and she'll say absolutely
not don't say that second thing you'll
sound like an idiot or you're trying to
fight or something and i'll be like oh
good
so let's just practice
practice okay
take the shame of i'm a failure and i'm
a loser and i'm always going to be a
wimp take that off okay and practice
this
here's another thing that's very
unpopular
okay
um it's unpopular
by certain members of
different media ecosystems okay
but i want you to start exercising do
you exercise regularly
no i don't okay
whether that's going to a gym and
signing up for like a local ymca and
getting one of the personal trainers for
14 bucks a shot or going to a local
jujitsu gym
or getting a pair of running shoes and
just committing to doing a 5k or
something here's what we're looking for
global confidence in daniel
okay i'm not i don't want you to like
go
you're not gonna go take krav maga so
you can fight everybody in your
neighborhood that's not what i'm saying
but what i am saying is you desperately
lack physical
confidence and i often tell young men
especially
you work and train and get in shape and
lift weights
so that you never have to do anything
with it
that's why
you know what i mean
yeah
so that you walk a little bit taller and
you in somebody um one of your family
members
does and by the way if you're walking
down the street and somebody like
disrespects you bro
just walk to the other side right i'm
not talking about getting in street
fights acting like an idiot but there is
hey
we will not be a part of this family
get-together because uncle so-and-so
continues to disrespect my wife
and i've mentioned it to him continues
to do it
we are opting out we're going to the
beach so
you all have fun
it's developing that confidence and
unfortunately i have not seen anywhere
where confidence is gained by just
talking more and more and more and more
and more
i've only seen true confidence gained in
doing hard things
step by step by step by step and
continuing to push that boundary more
and more and more it may be a yoga
practice for you but finding something
that's hard
with your body and leaning into that
okay so we got two things one i want you
to set up scenarios where you have to
practice
okay
um excuse me i ordered a large uh excuse
me i whatever and i want you to begin to
move in your body if you will do that
for 60 days i want you to loop back on
me and tell me how things are going will
you do that
yes will you commit to those two things
i will
well do not under any circumstances walk
into a gym and try to beefcake it out
dude
don't do that
or i definitely won't be able to do that
anyways yeah don't i mean i have a buddy
he did that once he went to the gym and
was just tried like arnold
schwarzenegger and he didn't he couldn't
wipe properly for three weeks right
because he's just so sore um get with
somebody who knows what they're doing or
just knock on the door of a local jiu
jitsu gym and say hey i want to learn
this this art and teach me this right
and we're going to go slow and you're
going to invest that money and that
investment is going to be in developing
confidence in daniel
and that confident i'm telling you right
now that confidence will ripple through
your work life through your marriage
through parenting through your families
through how you walk through your
community
man it'll be you'll you will end up
being such a radiant gift to those in
your life is that fair
yes i appreciate it thank you so much
you got it man all right you got 60 days
and by the way anybody listening to this
whether you're 75 or 65 or 35 or 15.
i wish there was a way we could talk
ourself into
confidence
but our bodies know
our bodies know and we end up just being
chihuahua was just barking
i cannot recommend enough having some
sort of practice on the daily where you
move your body especially lifting
weights especially engaging in some sort
of
physical
competition with other people especially
doing hard things
you will see confidence grow in every
other area of your life and not idiotic
confidence not oh yeah bro not that kind
of confidence but yes sir no certain
kind of confidence
strength and commitment kind of
confidence get good with a bow and arrow
get good with a
weed eater get good with things outside
and often those things can be used for
service too
and then just practice and feel your
body the whole way through when you're
practicing good for you my brother
daniel let this be the day that it all
changes let this be the day that it all
changes we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's gonna hurt you down the road and
most importantly when you're making this
big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert and a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan two hundred
trust me that's triple eight loan two
hundred
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
one five nine one in the mls consumer
access dot org equal housing lender 1749
mallory lane suite 100 brentwood
tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and are not available in
all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to
pre-anna
in lexington kentucky what's up brianna
hey how are you hey
good what's up
so my question is is um i'm married
and we have two kids
we have been having this discussion on
if we should have single friends or not
and i just wanted to ask you what your
thoughts were
tell me more
um well
if i go way back
there's been some infidelity in the past
and i think that's kind of where it's
stemming from
infidelity on my part
so
we had split up for
a year and a half
and we just got back together
and decided to work on things we both
have kind of changed and gotten therapy
and
medication to help with our anxiety and
depression
and then an issue came up the other day
and it was um
should we even be hanging out with
single people because
you know they might
they might influence me which i don't
think they would like my single
girlfriends
could influence me to do make a bad
choice that's just where he's coming
from so yeah
so
this is a complex question so walk me
back to the infidelity what happened
well um
i met up with
we weren't married we were we were
really young that still doesn't you know
obviously
um make my choice right really real
young 16 a real young 22
really young i was
19. okay all right yeah um
my ex had reached out to me my ex from
when i was like 15 16 reached out to me
he had just gotten
back from a navy like he did four years
in the navy
he reached out to me and said he wanted
to go out to eat um
and i said yes and that's how that was
and
um
my now husband found the messages
you know
you skipped over and that's how that was
so it started with dinner it ended with
well
no
no but it i wanted it to that's what the
messages were about uh okay okay and he
had enough in text so this was an
emotional
affair
yeah okay yeah um
and
i guess this guy was of character and he
said no
not doing that yeah okay
and so then y'all split up for a year
and a half tell me about that yeah
um well
we
were
um we had just
we were just newly married he was you
know we were stationed on an army base
in louisiana
and he started drinking heavily
um
the trust issues never got solved
um we just we isolated from everyone i
didn't feel like i could make friends
just a lot of toxicness and
um
depression and so
i left um i had mentioned to him a few
times like hey i'm not happy you know
i
shoot this is heavy um that's okay it's
all right i
i just you know the kids deserve better
i just
i just had my daughter she was three
months old our daughter she was three
months old
and he was not there he just wasn't
there
so i just picked up the kids one day and
just left like out of the
with no questions asked because i had
felt like i told him and he wasn't
hearing me
and i'd ever offered all these other
suggestions like hey you know i'll just
move out of the house and
go get a house off of base you know so
you can still be around the kids until
you get out of the army
and he just wasn't having it so are you
are you in
are you enlisted no okay no um
and so then what brought you back
together a year and a half later
um
it's a good we went on like this um a
little vacation together as a family and
he
had mentioned to me that you know he
just he loves me he doesn't he doesn't
he wants to be the husband and dad that
he knows he can be
and i felt the same way um
i'd been in church for the past year and
a half and i had been talking to him
about it like when he would call and
talk to the kids and
um all right you know i felt like god
was bringing us back together
sometimes
i i hesitate because the
some of the faith community will will be
mean to me on the internets when i say
this but
sometimes we attribute god's calling us
into a thing
but we are not fully in it
and it can get us in a mess okay
so okay
uh god very may well be calling you into
things great but i still want you to go
in there fully ready to rock and roll
with what comes your way okay
um
here's how i would answer that question
before you gave me the back story
okay i've got
our
i've been married we'll celebrate 20
years here in a few weeks been married a
long time and we got friends all over
the place of all different
shapes and sizes and marital status
any kind of friend you can imagine right
i've got friends that would make bernie
sanders be like whoa let's walk this one
back to the middle some and i got
friends who would make trump be like all
right that's too far even for me so i
i've got we have friends everywhere okay
yeah um
if you were to say is it wise for
somebody who's
a newlywed or
is it wise for anybody who's married to
go
hang out and
go do stuff and go grab drinks or
whatever with somebody who's of the
opposite gender than you and they're not
married that's not wise just not and i
know that put that has a whole bunch of
implications down the road with gender
equity all that i get all that it's not
wise it's not been wise and milo it's
just not wise right
um yeah i it doesn't even
it wouldn't even enter my mind if you
went and hung out with a bunch of
girlfriends um who are all hanging out
right and
they're not some of them aren't married
i that that isn't weird to me unless
you've got a friend who's like
dude cheat on your husband do it do it
and i don't know anybody
maybe those friends exist
none of my friends are like that
uh in fact i know friends like that
exist somewhere
your situation's a little bit different
um it sounds like you'll still have not
had
the conversation you need to have about
trust and here's what you all need the
conversation you need to have
what do you need from me
to help you
meet your needs
so that
you can help me
meet my needs
and what that means is both of you have
to sit down and say here's what i need
i need you to be home when you're here i
need to be off your phone
i need to have sex with you three times
or five times a week or one time a week
i need to go for walks with you i need
an hour of gym time i need it to be
quiet in the morning when we get up i
need to be laughing and hugging in the
morning and wake up
what do you need
and then how can i
dedicate my life to helping you meet
those needs
and you vice versa you see how that
works okay yeah that's a totally
different approach to can i do this or
can i do that
yeah see what i'm saying i like that
yeah and
any sort of can i do this or i want to
do that but i can't do that that's never
getting to the surface of here's what i
need from you
and
man
you will see your entire relationship
roll over
when you say i need you and your home to
be fully present those needs and they do
inform behaviors and that means they
need you off your phone that means you
can't come home and drink three beers
and then expect to play with the kids
because you're not gonna be present with
them that means they need to turn the tv
off and turn halo off and go outside and
kick a soccer ball with our little one
right
i need help at bedtime it's sitting down
and this could be a lot of fun for the
two of you if you have this spirit it
could be a
whining and complaining and grenade
throwing fast
or it could be a blast depending on the
attitude you all both take going into
this
and so
i would recommend this you've heard me
recognize a million times and i'll keep
doing it i think y'all should have
somebody watch your kids and y'all go
have a day retreat
and
have something cool at the end of the
day
some sort of romantic rendezvous that
y'all are both into and start at square
one and say all right we're going to
rebuild this thing from the floor up
what is this what do we want this thing
to look like
and what do i need and by the way needs
change a lot
throughout a marriage and so you're
gonna do this again next year you're
gonna do it the year after that and the
year after that
and
man it's so great
it's so great you know what i mean
yeah it sounds it sounds good um
it's just uh
what is it i don't know um what is
it i
i struggle sometimes i think like i've
which i get offended a lot which i'm
working on but um i feel like
in a way he's trying to control me but
he he tells me you know he probably is
controlling you he probably is yeah
because he doesn't want you to cheat on
him again
yeah he's really he's really hurt by it
yeah and most of the time we default to
our
um
our
we default to our default setting right
when something bad happens and some
people detach
some people start swinging fists some
people tighten up even tighter
right
everybody has a default setting and so
in an effort to keep you
from leaving him or cheating on him
again
he's going to suffocate you
yeah in an effort
for you to keep him happy you're going
to slowly drown yourself you see it
doesn't just they never work that way
yeah and so let's do this let's look at
the last two three four years of your
relationship and say okay what we've
tried so far isn't working let's try
something different
let's try taking our hands off the wheel
and let's try looking at each other
because here's the thing
when you were trying to cheat on him you
didn't like yourself yeah
yeah i really didn't there's something
about you that you were trying to a hole
you were trying to like i mean there was
a thing missing that you were trying to
wrap your heart around and
man
i want you to find that with him and
that starts with you saying here's what
i need and that starts with him saying
here's what i need and you quit being
offended if he says hey i don't like it
when you do this i love when you do this
say
yes i've got new data
i'll tell you something embarrassing can
i say something embarrassing yeah it was
we've been married 16 years i think our
marriage was hanging on by a a string of
dental floss okay
and we said basically we we're at this
very same like we have to just be honest
and say what it is what it is what it is
like here's what i need here here's what
i need here and i said the words now
remember i'm a six foot two 195 pound
texas mail
right
and i said the words
i have been chasing
you
i have been chasing the words i'm proud
of you from you for 25 years we dated a
long time
yeah
it would really mean the world to me if
you would say the words i'm pr i'm proud
of you
and dude it was i felt like such a
weakling such a coward and such a baby
for saying that out loud
but it was the truth and she
dropped her shoulders and said if i had
known that 25 years ago i would say that
every day
and it was something i needed that i had
it was a tool that i had i had kept from
her right and so now
um
now that sort of conversation happens on
the regular my house hey what do you
need what do you need for today what
does today look like for you how can i
be a part of that
i already can tell you i'm gonna need
help with bedtime on it consider bedtime
done with the kids
um i'll take care of the dogs and the
chickens whatever the thing is right
and so
it's it's sitting down saying i need
this and he may say i need total
fidelity from you
i need to be able to go off and do my
thing and not wonder for one second
is she texting some other dude
and so for you that might mean like i'm
not gonna hang out with people who
aren't married i'm gonna hang out with
couples only because that's that's that
is gonna be a gift to him and hey honey
here's what i need from you i need you
to show up at home see what i'm saying
yeah and we're going to do that sucker
together and
for 99 of the world that's entering into
territory they've never seen done that
way they've never seen relationships or
marriages work like that
and so it feels it feels like you're
giving up power it feels like you are
becoming less than
because you're taking a knee at somebody
it's
in front of somebody else and saying you
could really hurt me bad but i'm going
to spend my days trying to meet your
needs
with the understanding that you're
trying to meet mine
and let's get through life together and
it sounds transactional it's not it
sounds like there's an roi here there's
not they're simply i want to love you
better so that you can love me better so
that i can love you better and then
you're talking about
roots on a tree that go to the center of
the earth
and then questions like can i hang out
with unmer those questions just go away
they just go away they're just not or
when they do pop up you shoot you give
your husband a call like hey so-and-so's
in town would it be weird if i and he
may say yeah i don't care at all ah that
makes me feel and you're like sweet cool
no problem and you're on to the next
you're on to the next
so for whatever that's worth um that'd
be my recommendation and please go into
it with a spirit of this can be a lot of
fun and go into it with a spirit of i
refuse to be offended because my
husband's gonna give me some data on how
i can love him better
and i'm going to give him some data on
how he can love me better and we're
going to make this thing special we'll
be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloni.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we're back as we wrap up
today's show
man we're going with the great glenn
hansard
actually this guy's one of the greatest
song writers on the planet song is song
of good hope and it goes like this
if we're gonna make it cross this river
alive we need to think like a boat and
go with the tide and i know where you've
been it's really left you in doubt of
ever finding a harbor or figuring this
out and you're gonna need all the help
you can get so lift up your arms now and
reach for it may the song of good hope
walk with you through everything we're
here to walk with you we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode no do you
know if you have hemorrhoids i don't
think i've had them and there's the
family here right before the show i was
talking we're talking about a segment
that sarah has edited i just said you
were like you were this show's
preparation h and i meant that as a
great compliment what what about the
situation makes you feel unsafe this
person
stabbed someone that's it i wasn't
sticking to
the aaa meetings that she asked me to do
normally
it's not the alcohol
it's the person you become when you
drink
[Music]